last chance saloon
from midnight on friday new rules in
london and other parts of england
will ban the mixing of different
households inside
all part of the government's localized
response to rising infection rates
a move the prime minister said avoided
the need for another
national lockdown some have argued that
we should introduce
a national lock down instead of targeted
local action and i disagree closing
businesses in cornwall
where transmission is low will not cut
transmission
in manchester so while i can't rule
anything out
if at all possible i want to avoid
another
national lock down with the damaging
health economic
and social effects it would have in the
capital
up to six people for mixed households or
support bubbles
can still meet outside where there's
little infection risk
leading to some creative ways of
bringing people together
winter's coming and britain's bracing
for a season out in the cold
there's growing anger over the social
economic and health costs of curtailing
people's freedom
the prime minister boris johnson is
walking a delicate tightrope between
those who say his measures are far too
restrictive
and those who believe the government
isn't going far enough in trying to stop
this virus in its tracks
a bitter argument also erupted between
the british government and leaders in
the north of england
the mayor of manchester's warned of dire
consequences for the local economy
if forced to accept the toughest
coronavirus restrictions
including a complete ban on social
gatherings
the united kingdom has europe's highest
official death toll
but cases are soaring across europe with
around a hundred thousand infections a
day
the czech republic's building the
country's first makeshift hospital to
cope with europe's fastest rise in cases
more than four thousand hospital staff
are now infected
in some of the most drastic measures
paris and other major french cities
will be under nightly curfews for four
weeks starting on saturday
many businesses across europe were
counting on the christmas season
to help bolster sales and protect jobs
instead europe now responsible for a
third of all global
cases is bracing for a winter of deep
discontent
neve barker al jazeera london